you
hello there fortnite's narrative has
been an enigma for Years yet chapter 4
attempts to give us more backstory than
ever before the Ageless the rift Warden
and Amy's desire to save the scientist
it's now time to recap the season I'm
Adam you're awesome let's do this
quickly a quick recap of how we got here
we joined forces with a troop called the
seven a resistance group of space
Travelers caught up in a war with
another faction the imagined order both
groups sole purpose is gaining control
of the zero point by any means necessary
that orb of power is the big bang you
learn about at school the energy that
created all life and all existence but
that's where the similarities between
the 7 and IO end as the imagined order
want to harness the Zero Point Energy
for their own means while the seven wish
to free it during our time in game we
worked with both sides finally teaming
with the seven to free the zero point
and send everyone home in chapter three
job done or was it the zero point
freedom is all well and good but let's
be honest someone out there will always
want to possess that power or Worse
destroy it a mere few weeks later our
Paradise was dismantled a mysterious
substance eventually consumes the entire
Island along with most of the seven long
story short another faction known as the
last reality made a daring play to claim
the zero point but it all ended with the
entire Island exploding
chapter 4 begins now I've done
everything this is your fight now
somehow the zero point with help from
the last remaining member of the seven
the Paradigm built a new island for us
dragging together chunks of land mass
from multiple realities and more to the
point from multiple time periods modern
day buildings stood close to Medieval
structures the past the present and the
future all at the same time
the zero point now hides in a vault
underfoot in a world controlled by a new
enemy the Ageless a formidable Champion
attacks any Outsiders in his presence
with new technology never seen before a
kinetic ore hammer and an Excalibur
rifle a gun that shoots swords wow we
believe the Ageless is a snapshot of
Geno the leader of the imagined order as
his sigil can be spotted on the flags
and he looks Mighty similar too the last
time we saw Geno he was ripped into a
million pieces but he didn't stay dead
for long the NPCs in this new world are
already choosing aside to serve the
Ageless or to prepare to battle him we
didn't come to the island all alone
before he was covered in goo the
scientist introduced us to Amy an AI
unit with very strong opinions I
am so it shall be working with her we
take rocks from paradigm's Homeworld to
a quarry of unimaginable power under
Revelation is made
I could mind blend this island into a
big old existing smoothie
wanted to wish I
totally legal
we've made a new power source and
immediately Amy gives the new discovery
to stellen I'll let him explain himself
might ask set by the Ageless Champion it
create a stable Rift gate Bridge
so stellen is basically creating an
early version of the bridge in fortnite
lore IO used it to harness the Zero
Point Energy to travel anywhere in
existence stellen has already started
work for his boss the of bound and began
construction on a turret roof and like
always we somehow became his assistant
at one point we created a planetary
chart using the Vault where the zero
point is this was to allow Stellan to
pinpoint where in the cosmos we are
before we could complete the build
during our time with stellen he
eventually trusts us enough to share a
secret
secret I have
I have a shapeless man
he watches us with dark
if we do not finish the rift gate the
consequences will be
terrible a shapeless man watches the
island this could be countless people in
fortnite's law from the Chrome goodness
of the herald to the Chaos Agent who is
made out of whatever this substance is
to Geno himself who is currently piecing
himself back together after a Out of
Body Experience he could even be a
member of the seven they became gula's
chapter 2 and then there is a name we
know little about the nothing during
chapter 3 we saw the nothing convince
one of our own soldiers to join his
cause but there hasn't been a word since
all we know for certain right now is a
shapeless man who watches the island
[Music]
Amy is rightfully a little perturbed by
what Stellan says and decides to do a
little investigating
suspicious to you she wants to hijack
stellen's riftgate idea to find the
scientist her Creator as Amy doesn't
have a body yet we do the donkey work
yet again grabbing everyday items
shoving AI chips into them and yating
them through a miniature version of a
riftgate moments later the object
returns but holy heck look at them
they've been changed by the rift but the
only question we care about is is the
scientist still alive
foreign
[Music]
oh wow yes indeed by the sounds of it
they found all the chromed Islanders
from the last chapter sadly they aren't
having the greatest of times wherever
they are and if you needed more proof
finally Amy confirms the scientist can
be saved
our plan is now simple assist Stellan
with the rift gate and at the very
moment he switches it on we hijack it to
find the scientist
[Music]
the build can
build can get a little closer to
construction and our closeness to
stellen continues and he can't help but
tell us another one of his secrets
destroy us the shapeless man he speaks
of told him to go to the oath bound with
the sole purpose of creating a rift gate
the Ageless is just another Pawn in this
story like us the shapeless man torment
stellen into doing his bidding meanwhile
Amy is preparing to save the scientist
and for that she needs a physical body
to survive the jump through the rift so
she uses an old Aimbot with a highly
advanced piece of tech taped to its head
welcome to the Future and then it
becomes Time to Say Goodbye to Amy and
it looks like she's going to have a
villain Arch soon listen to this
goodbye not forever but for now I don't
know what's happening to the scientist
but I will find him
and I'll bring him back here
and maybe when I do I'll look at
everything I've done and he'll finally
see me as his Superior
thank you for everything you changed my
life
hello
I'll miss you that girl needs a
validation quick while this happened a
piece of law was given to us via a Blog
update it's based around two premium
characters from the crew packs that have
been confirmed to have defeated the
Ageless Champion using Excalibur rifles
whether that's important or not I really
don't know but it's better to know than
to not and now it's the final week of
the season the rift gate was completed
and began to rise into the air a
floating hula hoop of Destiny and Now's
the Time the rift gate is switched on
and it's revealed someone has changed
the coordinates how could that have
happened we go to the last place we saw
Amy and true to her word she has gone in
her place one of those Rifts if all goes
to plan Amy will return with the
scientist and the Seven our final
mission for stellen Caesar's locate
potential collaborators everyone admits
no guilt and stellan's last words for
shadow imminent danger
[Music]
keep an eye on this guy as the season
ends something huge is coming I'm Adam
you're awesome I'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign